and now I'd like to introduce our head
table guests and ask them to stand
briefly when their names are called from
your right
Katherine Skiba of US News and World
Report myron Belkin retired with AP and
the newly elected secretary of the club
Marc Hamrick of ap broadcast and our
membership secretary Renu ryo-san both
Kiplinger Melissa Charbonneau the vice
chairwoman of the speaker's committee
skipping over our speaker for just a
minute Bob Cardin of carding
communication and the speaker's
committee member who organized today's
event thank you so much Bob Donna line
one of USA Today and the president-elect
of the club
Andrew Schneider of Kiplinger Washington
editors and Timothy Berger of Bloomberg
welcome everyone there are few if any
columnist more influential than the New
York Times is Paul Krugman the
Washington Monthly has called him the
most important political columnist in
America
adding considerable heft to his
reputation the Nobel Committee awarded
Krugman the 2008 Nobel Prize for
economics for his analysis of the
economies of scale on international
trade
plus he does what really smart people
rarely do Krugman communicates in a way
that is accessible to people without
degrees in economics he does that
without being condescending or dumbing
down his thoughts and his many readers
are grateful we hope he'll give us a
flight plan out of our mess today or at
least enlighten us Paul Krugman grew up
in Long Island and received his
undergraduate degree at Yale and his
doctorate in economics at MIT in
addition to his perch at the New York
Times Krugman is a professor of
economics and international affairs at
Princeton University he is the author of
several books including conscience of a
liberal also the title of his blog and
return of the depression economics and
the crisis of 2008 hookans Krugman has
been a harsh and unrelenting critic of
the Bush administration's economic and
foreign policies he blames much of the
economic troubles on President Bush Alan
Greenspan and some of the more notable
arc
texts of deregulation including former
Republican senator Phil Gramm while
Krugman is certainly a liberal by
temperament and definition he has a
time-traveled the political spectrum he
worked for a short period for the Reagan
administration as a staff member for the
Council on economic advisers who might
have guessed that please help me give a
warm National Press Club welcome to Paul
Krugman
well thank you by the way I'd like to
take exception to being called a harsh
critic of the Bush administration's
economic and foreign policies I've also
been a harsh critic of its environmental
policies its judicial alright by the way
the that thing about the Reagan
administration yes I was there as a
technocrat that the council I was the
chief international staff for chief
domestic staffer was a guy by the name
of summers Larry Summers don't know what
happened anyway so just okay so I'm here
to talk at least obviously what's on
everybody's minds is the crisis and I
have a new book a new book which is a
much revised version of an old book
which is also about the crisis it's
called the return of depression
economics on the crisis of 2008 and I'm
going to structure these remarks around
what what that book is about and what
where that and and where we are right
now in the economy which are I think
more or less the same thing so let me
start maybe in an odd place trying to
think about this talk I I realized that
what was in my mind among other things
when I wrote depression economics in his
first version was a talk I'd heard many
years before from Alice Rivlin former
OMB chair at Brookings now I believe who
talked about how in policy there were
hard problems and easy problems there
easy easy problems were ones where you
might have a political hitch you
couldn't trying to figure out how to get
the necessary votes to pass what needed
to be done in Congress but you did know
what to do it was not fundamentally
conceptually hard so something like
finding enough money to repair the
highways is an easy problem hard
problems are things where we really
don't have good answers we don't know
really what we should be doing or we we
we have some things we might try we
don't really know how to how to bring
these things under control so something
like reducing the crime rate is a hard
problem we did it but we actually still
don't know how we did it so it's one of
those things that the
is really difficult in economics or in
macroeconomics and in managing the the
economy as a whole we had a traditional
division between heart problems and easy
problems stagflation is a hard problem
when you've got high inflation and
you're trying to bring it down but you
really don't want to have high
unemployment in the process we don't
know how to do that
stagflation was a hard problem no no one
in economics is puzzled by the fact that
it was very expensive and difficult to
bring the high inflation of the late
1970s down that was known to be a hard
problem on the other hand just plain
old-fashioned recession just plain lack
of demand there's not enough spending to
keep people fully employed that's
supposed to be an easy problem we we
thought we knew you know that you just
have the Fed print some more money maybe
you just have some federal spending but
mostly we thought that that pretty much
uncle Alan or Uncle Ben or their
equivalent can can deal with with
ordinary recession type problems quite
easily demand is easy and it's not just
that that's that's not just the way
people talk occasionally they put it in
print so I actually begin the current
edition of depression economics with a
quote from Robert Lucas the very greedy
economist Nobel laureate from some years
back who gave as this presidential
address to the American Economic
Association he started by saying the
problem of depression prevention has
been solved this is not a problem
basically the lecture goes on to say we
should be worrying about long-run growth
because we know how to handle downturns
that's that's not a problem but actually
about 10 years ago I and a fair number
of other people began to have some real
doubts about whether the problem of
depression prevention had been solved
and that came initially out of the
experiences of Asian economies in crisis
looking at the problems of Indonesia
Thailand Malaysia South Korea and above
all Japan and saying you know maybe this
thing is not so easy to deal with
there was a little nest actually turns
out at Princeton of economists who were
deeply concerned who looked at in
particular at Japan and said you know
that could be us maybe the problems that
they're having in Japan are not so much
because of fundamental specific Japanese
problems but maybe they they suggest the
vulnerability that could be in all of
our economies that little nest of
economists included me of course
Lars fencin who's now at the Rick's Bank
in Sweden Mike Woodford and the guy by
the name of Ben Bernanke we all looked
at those problems and thought that you
know this this this may be an omen what
has happened in these Asian economies
could possibly happen to us as well and
of course now it has with hence the new
edition of the book and with and and
hence the my great concern that the
situation we're in so let me tell you
what it was that what I call depression
economics what it is that is the issue
here now the the normal way that we deal
with any slump the way we deal with the
downturn is for the central bank Federal
Reserve or the European Central Bank or
the Bank of Japan to deal with it by
essentially by printing money now it's
not quite that that's not literally what
they do they credit the accounts of
participating banks and buy short-term
government debt in return but open
market operations you increase you
basically push push money out there push
down the interest rates on short-term
government debt whether it's Treasury
bills or their equivalent in other
countries and that's normally enough to
get things moving lower interest rates
on the things that the Fed controls most
directly translated to lower interest
rates on things that matter to the
private sector so when you cut interest
rates when you cut the target Fed Funds
rate that eventually worked through to a
cut in mortgage interest rates cutting
corporate bond rates investment
increases there's more spending as
people is more spending the more income
and so on all down the line it doesn't
work instantly doesn't work with high
accuracy so you're always when you're
doing that kind of power
a little bit in the position of having a
thermostat that responds a little bit
slowly to the temperature in the room
and hence the temperature does fluctuate
but nothing really major and for a long
time we believed that we had this thing
pretty well down in fact just a few
years ago Ben Bernanke gave a speech
called the Great Moderation basically
arguing that because central bankers
like himself has figured out this stuff
out we had things reasonably well under
control not that we'd abolish the
business cycle but that we reduced it to
a kind of acceptable that the Wiggles
were small enough that we could we could
handle them them what happened in Asia
in the late 90s really shook that belief
among some of us on the one hand you had
a number of countries that found that
they could not apply the usual medicine
they could not go and cut interest rates
to try and fight their way out of a
recession because their currencies were
plunging and they're plunging currencies
exposed them to all kinds of financial
difficulties there they had companies
that had borrowed in dollars or in yen
they had a lot of balance sheet exposure
and as a result they were actually
finding themselves forced into raising
interest rates to try to defend their
currencies rather than cutting to fight
the recession and therefore experiencing
and in some cases real depression level
collapses and output so Indonesia was
probably the worst peacetime slump in
any in any reasonably large economy
since since the 1930s and and we saw
those things happening Japan had a
somewhat different problem but Japan had
a real estate and stock bubble which
burst and in the wake of that they did
they didn't have any inhibitions about
cutting interest rates and so they went
and they cut interest rates and they cut
interest rates and they cut interest
rates all the way to zero and it wasn't
enough Japan found itself in something
economists have known about for a long
time but I've managed to sort of push
out of their memory which is the
liquidity trap it's a confusing name but
it basically means that
once you've got the interest rate down
to more or less zero increasing the
amount of money in circulation doesn't
matter because money and your you
already people are already have as much
liquidity as much cash as they want
money is more or less equivalent to just
other stores of value can't push the
interest rate below zero because if
interest rates are below zero you'd do
better by putting the stuff in your
mattress so what you do if you push out
more cash is you just alter a basically
meaningless division of the amount of of
short-term stuff between money and zero
interest paper has no effect on the real
economy you have no traction for at
least from ordinary monetary policy now
their liquidity trap was a big issue in
the 1930s the the concern that the sense
that monetary that the Federal Reserve
at that point had had no ability to
manage the economy but as I like to say
economists have managed to convince
themselves with the passage of time
that's just things can't happen didn't
happen and furthermore would never
happen again
that we were not going to find ourselves
and I remember not long ago we would
look at the Great Depression look at
1935 and say wow look at that at that
point the interest rate on three-month
Treasury bills was down to your just
0.14 percent imagine that
yesterday it was 0.005 so if you want to
know how much we've recreated depression
conditions so we've got a crisis now and
I'm not going to talk a lot about how we
got into that crisis that's than many
things that just to say that some people
say that what we're seeing here is like
nothing we've ever seen before I think
it's actually more accurate to say that
it's like everything we've seen before
all at once
there's a real kind of sum of all fears
quality so the 1930s began the what made
the Great Depression great was not the
stock market crash but the banking
failures of the early 1930s what we've
essentially replicated that experience
not with traditional conventional banks
if your definition of a bank is
something that that lives in a big
marble building and has an fdic-insured
sign in the window then they're fine
okay a few you know we're about a 2 or 3
gets seized by the FDIC every Friday but
but but that's alright they're
continuing to operate the trouble is
that it something that doesn't have to
look like a traditional bank to be in
the banking business and so it turns out
we had grown over the years this very
large parallel banking system shadow
banking system whatever you want to call
it investment banks hedge funds asset
backed commercial paper money market
funds auction rate securities all of
these things that we're basically doing
what a bank does which is to promise one
set of people ready access to their
money but maybe only a short delay and
promised to another set of people long
term financing and there's that that's
most the time it works that's what a
bank does a bank says we have your money
here whenever you want it but at the
same time it lends out most of it long
term well that works because ordinarily
most people don't want their money at
the same time but if people lose
confidence in the soundness of a
particular bank or the system as a whole
then you have a bank run and all hell
breaks loose
we protected against bank runs with
deposit insurance and then regulations
on banks capital requirements reserve
requirements and so on but we grew up
this other system which is the shadow
banking system things that do Bank like
activity but were not called banks we're
not depository institutions we're not
regulated like banks and that system has
largely collapsed and for what is worth
that system was bigger on the eve of the
crisis than the conventional banking
system
Tim Geithner Treasury secretary
designate gave a speech last summer in
which he sort of tracked it through and
it was at least ten trillion dollars of
stuff and of course hasn't all
disappeared but it has shrunk massively
in what is basically a 21st century
version of the bank runs that ushered in
the Great Depression
currency crises
the kinds of things that had happened to
South Korea Indonesia and later
Argentina well we've got those two we
tend to think of the financial crisis as
being the product of the US housing
bubble subprime and then the
consequences of the burst of the housing
bubble and subprime turning into toxic
waste and that is a large part of the
story but there were other there were
other bubbles other misalignments that
have also gone bad in the last year and
a half and if we were gonna look the I
think probably the second biggest after
the US housing market the second biggest
source of a shock in the world today is
is the problems of the European
periphery the problems of countries that
attracted very large inflows of capital
in the last few years out of the belief
that well they were all going to be
members of the eurozone pretty soon and
they were safe and hey it's all Europe
and what can go wrong and if you look at
the size of the of the trade deficits
run by some of these countries they
actually relative to their economies
they actually dwarf what happened in in
Southeast Asia and the run-up to the 90s
crisis and now they're all experiencing
crises that are more or less are very
close cousins of the crises that took
place in in Southeast Asia and then in
in Argentina some years ago it's
actually astonishing how how blithely
everybody rushed into a almost complete
recreation of the crises that we all
worried about in the 90s so my line now
is that Latvia is the new Argentina and
Ukraine is the new Indonesia it's really
very similar and this is big stuff
individually these are not large
economies but take them all together
take in the bursting of the Spanish
housing bubble the British housing
bubble and you've got something which is
a sort of second epicenter of the crisis
not much smaller than the one we've
generated here so we've got the sum of
all fears sort of coming together all of
these crises freeze up in the credit
markets
huge increase in the spreads between the
interest rates at which the government
can borrow which at the short end
they're now zero and the interest rates
that the private sector has to pay all
of that puts a lot of downward pressure
on spending very large shrinkage and
private demand current numbers are just
you know numbers giving you some
indication of where the economy is
moving right now are generally quite
frightening basically I fire up my
computer every morning take a look at
the latest economic numbers and
generally say something I can't print in
the times because it's just uh it's a
really really bad stuff day after day
okay what do you do because that's where
really where we are now what what are
the possible options and what what do we
think is going to happen so as I said
there was a you know there was a group
of us at Princeton not just there but a
long number of economists were worrying
about this number of people looked at
Japan and the 90s and and said gee this
this looks a lot like us a big advanced
sophisticated country with stable
government and yet they're having a lot
of trouble what can we do to avoid
expect if we're starting to look
Japanese what can we do to to avoid a
similar experience Ben Bernanke of
course did quite a lot and if you look
at what's their policy responses have
been so far to me at least looks a lot
like we're moving down a checklist so
one of the things people staffers at the
Fed had argued for some time that the
Japanese might have been able actually
they were a little stronger they said
the Japanese would have been able to
avoid their loss decade if they had
responded aggressively with interest
rate cuts very early instead of
gradually working their way down to that
zero interest rate so the Fed has done
that very fast rapid interest rate cuts
that quite clearly has not worked
it probably has mitigated probably the
crisis would have been even worse if the
Fed had been less quick to respond and
at least we have to to the credit of the
Fed they
they kept their eye on the ball it's
astonishing right now to realize that
not that long ago the European Central
Bank was actually raising interest rates
because they had managed to convince
themselves that inflation was the
problem not not the the possibility of a
second Great Depression but in any case
that has not been enough conventional
monetary policy is now at its limit the
normal thing the Fed does is to work at
the short end and only on government
security so it buys Treasury bills and
pushes interest rates to have we now
we've now we're now at the zerp point
that's zero interest rate policy so
we're now served and that's not gonna
work
well okay that was Bernanke 2002 so we
move up to Bernanke and Reinhart 2004
which is changing the composition of the
central bank's balance sheet otherwise
known as having the Fed buy a lot of
stuff which isn't quite as safe as
buying short-term as buying Treasury
bills in the hope that essentially by
the Fed itself becoming a major lender
it can loosen up the markets and it's
doing that on an awesome scale so the
Fed Reserve had about eight hundred
billion dollars worth of assets not long
ago all of it pretty much short-term US
government debt it's now up to two trill
two and a half trillion I believe and
it's buying commercial paper essentially
essentially lending to private business
its buying mortgage-backed securities
from Fannie and Freddie which is a
little bit peculiar because this is one
sort of kind of part of the US
government the Federal Reserve buying
stuff from another sort of kind of part
of the US government now that Fannie and
Freddie have been are in conservatorship
but still it's it's it's not your normal
kind of policy and there'll clearly
continue to push stuff out actually my
wife says that the the logical limit
which will really reach within a few
years is we'll all have credit cards
with the Federal Reserve logo on them
but they're doing this enormous stuff
what I think I would say and this is
does it work I think the answer is yes
but to look particularly in the last few
weeks it does look as if they have
achieved something with these policies
mortgage rates have come down interest
rates on some private sector borrowing
have come down things are a little bit
better there's been a significant
loosening really really since about
middle the middle of October thanks to
all of this incredibly aggressive Fed
action but it's clearly not enough the
economy is headed downhill very fast now
at this point in fact the the even if
you've got a significant loosening in
the financial markets we'd probably be
heading downhill quite fast
the so III that there's a kind of a
black art to figuring out not what's
going to happen but even what is
happening right now because official
statistics lag but for what it's worth
it a reasonable guess is that we're
bleeding jobs at the rate of around
600,000 a month that the economy is
shrinking at a rate of about 6% right
now this is a pretty steep nosedive
going on in the economy and of course it
feeds on itself as the economy sinks
businesses scaled back their investment
plans because you know why add capacity
if you're going to have a sharp drop in
demand
consumers scaled back because even if
you have a job right now who knows and
so we get all of this downward pressure
what can you do well what the textbook
says is fiscal policy you can have the
government deliberately promote spending
now we had an attempt of fiscal policy
earlier this year which probably
achieved something that's there was so
much downward pressure in the economy
that is hard to tell but it had two
problems one was that it was too small
around 1% of GDP which looks trivial
compared to the size of our problems the
other is it was in the form of giving
people money and hoping they'll spend it
which is very dubious proposition right
now and we don't really know how much of
it was spent that's a very hard question
to answer but
not not too much certainly not enough so
what you really want to do now is the
surefire thing is to spend directly have
the government do infrastructure have
the government of course you know build
bridge repair bridges build roads fix up
schools all of that having doing
double-duty with luck you end up with
something of lasting value after it's
all over but in the meantime you also
are very definitely actually spending
money and supporting the economy
problems what I'd say is that the that
the problem that I worry about greatly
now I'm sorry let me let me back up for
a second size how big should this all be
and we're now hearing reports of 850
billion over two years from the incoming
administration which is actually almost
certainly not enough to really bring the
economy back anywhere close to full
employment although I can understand why
they're reluctant to have to hit the big
t and go up to a trillion let me just
give you my back of the envelope I'm
sorry I'm gonna get a little Walker's
for a second here we think that the
multiplier right you spend you build a
bridge the people you hire to build the
bridge then have more money and they go
and buy more consumer goods they go by
that creates more jobs and so on but
even when all of that is said and done
we think that the dollar of federal
spending probably creates only something
like a dollar and a half of GDP more
than more than the amount you spend but
not not vastly larger that means that if
you do 200 billion of spending that's
probably 300 billion of GDP which is 2
percent and it takes about 2 percent
rise in GDP to shave 1 percent off the
unemployment rate so sorry about that
the basically 200 billion for a year to
reduce the unemployment rate in that
year by one percentage point that's a
rough number we're probably on a track
absent policy intervention to have an
unemployment rate of between 9 and 10
percent by the end
this year so you start to think about
that you see that 850 billion over 2
years is not a lot of money it's
actually well short of what we would
probably need to get anywhere close to a
let's have 5 percent unemployment rate
why not
just go ahead and do more key problem
right now is time and speed
infrastructure spending is clearly I'd
say clearly the best thing we could do
right now the problem is you can't just
say okay let's start let's start doing
major environmental initiatives and
spend the money starting next week takes
time takes time to stuff get stuff going
so the question is the the term I'm sure
everybody's heard it now is shovel ready
how much shovel ready stuff do we have
and shovel ready actually doesn't mean
you can start next week shovel ready
generally means you can start within six
months and even so there are limits so
I'm seeing numbers like next 150 billion
dollars of shovel ready now maybe we've
got some very smart people very creative
people coming in maybe they can find
more of that but the immediate problem
is actually going to be how can you get
enough stuff going in time to slow this
economy's nosedive I will be shocked if
despite everything that the Obama people
are trying to do if they can stop the
unemployment rate before 8% in fact I
might guess it will hit 9% before they
finally are getting enough traction to
turn it around late late this year I
mean I these things you know he kind of
economic forecasts are are not exactly
precise but it's it's going to be very
difficult the problem immediately now is
really one of speed getting the stuff
going you can try other stuff you can
try some things are faster aid to the
unemployed eight state local governments
because one of the one thing you can do
quickly if you can't start spending
quickly you can avert cuts in spending
fairly quickly so eight state local
governments all of that we're hearing
about but it's going to be really really
hard how does this all end
I think I'm quite optimistic I'm scared
to death of next next year I'm quite
optimistic about the year after that
because then the stimulus will be coming
online and we will be getting a lot of
boost and the team coming into the white
house does understand that they
understand the economy they they you
know at least as well as anyone does
they understand the needs I start to get
concerned again once you look further
out because I take a look and say well
okay we do know how to boost the economy
if we do a lot of federal spending that
will boost the economy we can't do it
our immediate problem is how to do it
fast enough what I don't know is what
the end game looks like eventually you
want the private economy to step back in
you want to withdraw this eventually we
have to start worrying about servicing
the debt we've run up in the course of
the stimulus program but I don't have a
clear story about which part of the
private sector takes up the slack after
the federal government after the
stimulus is done hopefully we'll get a
better read on that a little bit further
out but that is going to be a big issue
we we look at the the Great Depression
was ended by a large public works
program known as World War two what we
really don't still don't understand very
well is why when the war was over the
depression didn't come back we actually
don't know that very well and that's
that's a question that I think we're
kind of want to think about quite a lot
and it's modern guys as we look forward
scary times you know professionally
there is a part of me that says you know
this is this is the crisis I always
wanted to live through because this is
what you know in the comments ass type
but of course is as a actually human
being it's it's it's horrific it's it is
awesomely dangerous I don't think
although I think we clearly are back in
depression economics I don't think we're
actually talking about another
depression but there's only reason one
reason for that it's not that the things
that made the Great Depression happened
are impossible in the modern world in
fact
exactly those things and a 21st century
version are happening right now the only
thing that means that will prevent us
from having another Great Depression is
that I think we learned something from
the last time we had this experience and
that we have some idea of how to of how
to avert the worst so everything right
now hinges on whether we've got whether
we understand this stuff even as well as
I think we do and and whether the tools
that are at hand are enough to pull us
back from the brink I think so not quite
as confident of that as I would even I
would have been a year ago scary times
let's wish us let's wish ourselves the
best of luck thanks
okay we might have to extend this lunch
for another hour we've got so many
questions here some of the questioners
says someone suggested stimulus checks
to people written in disappearing ink so
that they have to spend it within 30
days can't deposit it in a bank or
anything what do you think of an idea of
something like that actually the the
Germans were have proposed exactly that
I mean not disappearing but but time
they did stimulus but the trouble is
people are it's still fungible right I
mean it give me a check that will
disappear in a month and I will spend it
and and you know substitute spending
from that check with spending I would
have done from other funds so only
people who are liquidity constrained I'm
trying to think of a way to say that in
English and I can't are gonna now you
know there's there's an issue it might
be that that we're being too rational
about this that people really would
spend it faster but but no that's really
issue and I understand it in Germany
people are protesting against the
proposal saying well I should have the
right to save it if I want but yeah it's
not it's not as easy that there are
there are there are other proposals that
we issue time dated currency which
depreciate some value so that we can
have negative interest rates but anyway
never mind if we have a huge stimulus
package and if somebody even uses the T
word trillion it doesn't really matter
what it's spent on you mean you said
that shovel-ready projects are important
but Alice Rivlin had warned against the
being misspent can you really miss spend
a government stimulus package yeah I
mean other things equal it should be
spent well if you can but no this is
where but what's all right yeah well you
should be on stuff if you can on stuff
that is actually valuable so we really
do have bridges falling down and we
should fix them and all that but no I
mean this is my great Idol in case
people haven't figured this out from my
writings is John Maynard Keynes and
Keynes wrote talking about the
reluctance to spend on you know on
projects and all the complaints that
people had he said well let's we can
solve this by bear
burying bottles full of cash and coal
mines and then letting the private
sector dig them up and he said it would
be it would be better to spend on
something useful he said but you know
but but if that's the only thing people
accept let's do that so no I mean I to a
large extent now there there's a
political concern which is if you're
going to be a democratic progressive
big-spending administration you had not
probably be very very careful that the
thing that look is squeaky clean
so the WPA was amazingly clean and it
was that was by design there were
multiple layers of oversight to make
sure that the money was that that
whether or not the projects were good at
least there was no corruption hardly any
corruption it was there were desperate
attempts to find corruption and they
didn't weren't very successful that's
gonna slow up the projects but I'm
afraid that has to be done I think in in
the real you know and from a straight
economic point of view better to to kill
a lot of money to Tony Soprano and get
it out there fast but in and I'm from
New Jersey
but but in the real world they do I'm
not sure that the quality of the
projects is as critical as Alice thinks
it is but I think that the quality of
the oversight is do you think there are
any of those just depression-era
programs WPA and the arts programs and
everything could they be brought back or
is it just a different time that we're
in you know I've actually wondered about
I would if we would throw 1/10 of 1% of
this thing and act culture what
wonderful things could happen but I have
a suspicion that just can't be done in
this modern world that that we would the
culture wars are just too intense for us
to do that but the WPA you know I don't
think people are not going to be WPA had
a kind of an ethos around it and and was
was billed as something more than just a
quick emergency measure I don't think
people are ready for that I mean right
now we just do stuff that that looks
useful and we'll get the demand out
there so it's going to be
straightforward things like like fixing
bridges like my pet project though I
don't I don't know how I've been getting
conflicting reports on how shovel-ready
it is but I want that second rail tunnel
under the Hudson for personal reasons so
that sort of thing up upgrade its so I
think it's it's going to be much more
prosaic than the WPA was how about
defense spending in the context of this
do you think that's a good idea
not so you know it doesn't really matter
on the point of a stimulus what kind of
spending it is so yeah I mean as I said
the world the World War two ended the
Great Depression it was the NASA
spending on on on weaponry that that
actually did it now I don't think that I
I don't think there's actually an urgent
need for us you know if they're if
they're defense priorities that really
should be done and are shovel-ready fine
but I suspect that that's not the case
and I don't think that in any case I
think given the mood of the country to
say well we're going to do this on a
defense build-up is probably not the
best idea we need to ask you to comment
on the news of the day which is better
an orderly bankruptcy for the auto
industry the emergency loans that were
announced today
oh I mean those are not either/or yeah I
I'm sure there are lawyers in the room
who know better than I whether whether
or not it actually has to be a chapter
11 but you know what's going to happen
almost surely for the auto industry is
in fact a an orderly bankruptcy a
packaged prepackaged bankruptcy it's
going to be they're gonna have to find
some way to abrogate a lot of contracts
they don't have to find some way to to
put the put off a number of debt
payments but it has to come with a dip
financing is non-existent so it has to
come from the federal government people
won't buy cars from a company or will be
reluctant buy cars from a company that
might not exist there have to be
warranties from the federal government
so
a whole bunch of stuff that has to
surround the bankruptcy proceeding and
the reason for this emergency loan is
you can't do that in a matter of days we
can't there's no way that kind of
package can be put together now
especially with lame-duck administration
lame-duck Congress so the whole purpose
of this loan is to it's is to kick the
can down the road but that's productive
in this case you push it that back and
so in early next year the next
administration and the and the new
Congress can put together a more lasting
solution so I think this this is not a
contradiction and you know we'll the the
big fix for the auto industry that
probably will come in February whatever
will that actually work or will that
just postpone the death a little while
and the answer is we don't know the
answer to that but the one thing you
don't want to do is out of sheer
inability to get your act together let
that industry just go under right in the
middle of this horrifying downturn
that's that's a massive anti stimulus
program you don't want to implement you
make the point that in economic slumps
it's almost a patriotic duty for the
rich to spend spend spend in the off
chance they're any rich members of the
National Press Club what kind of
consumption gets the most bang for the
buck so to speak if the underlying goal
is to help the economy you know I just
don't think this is this is the way you
make policy by urging people to spend as
they're patriotic and which we you know
after 9/11 I thought that was although I
understood the point but you know there
was President Bush and also former
President Clinton actually both went out
there urging people to keep spending and
actually publishes that there was this
ad that was all over taking on the
airport TVs with from the travel agents
association with President Bush saying
do your business around the country
which obviously doesn't quite have the
same connotation elsewhere that it does
in New Jersey but anyway um the but that
just had a bad
even though it was made economic sense
just had for me a bat morally bad feel
at times of stress you don't call on
people to to not make sacrifices and I
you know I just thought this is this is
not the job of the individual consumer
that said I guess what you what you want
to do is you want to think of what what
is got the lowest import content as
possible right if you want to spend on
on haircuts and and personal services
and and not go buy lots of poison toys
and paint to see food from China or you
could see why it's a good thing I'm not
in the government says your blog
recently posed the question do we need a
middle class if not aren't we arguing
for trickle-down economics
yeah if those who don't read my blog the
question was just for the was really a
quite narrow question if we're asking do
you need to have a reasonably equal
distribution of income in order to have
sufficient consumer demand to sustain
the economy and lots of people say you
do but I think the math is wrong if you
actually ask can you have a society
which has sufficient consumer demand
where a lot of that consumer demand
consists of people buying lavish dinners
and and and staying at luxury hotels yes
you can in fact we did for you know for
many years before the 1930s and and to
some extent we did that through much of
the 80s and 90s it's not a quick it's
question of sufficient demand that's not
saying the society that doesn't have a
middle class which is more or less what
we are now is a good society I think
it's terrible in many ways but just the
mechanical the argument that sheer
Keynesian demand economics requires that
you have a row of the equal distribution
of income isn't right I mean some sense
I I it's a subject that in some ways
maybe I shouldn't even be raising
because it's a but but there is a
tendency for people to think that that
just to stimulate the economy we have to
have greater equality in this country
and I think that's not right that's a
that that's
economics is not a morality play
what-what-what's what's just is not
necessarily what you have to do in order
to simply then make the machine work how
would you rate the news media's handling
and coverage of the financial crisis oh
boy um I'm not this has not there been
there's not a lot of good reporting I
have to say I think I've probably found
more articles than that that I found
really illuminating on this then then
pretty much any previous era which is
partly just because there's a lot of
interesting stuff happening I think
there has been a lot of good reporting
and the by my my sense is actually that
the quality of economics reporting
that's why I'm not quite sure exam a
business but the quality of economics
reporting I believe has gone up quite a
lot in the last last decade that that
just that the general quality of
thinking understanding of the issues is
is better so I'm actually not not that
negative on you know this isn't this is
not like okay this is not like the
run-up to the Iraq war this is there has
not been a major dereliction what is
true is that on the specific issue of
housing this is if you read Dean Baker
of the Center for Economic Policy
Research has a regular blog at the
American Prospect that on basically on
business on reporting on on economic and
business issues and he buzzing on
economic issues and he makes the point
that throughout the run-up in housing
prices basically the only people who got
quoted in in most news stories were
people from the National Realtors
Association people who were essentially
Southside for the housing industry and
now that the housing bubble is burst
still for the most part the only people
who get quoted are people
were suicide for the housing industry
and almost it on the specific issue of
housing it is almost like Iraq
apparently you know you're not taken
seriously on national security unless
you are wrong about Iraq and you're not
taken seriously on housing unless you
are wrong about the bubble and why
that's true I don't quite understand but
that is a major hole in the coverage
question area asks what do you see is
the risk of protectionism at the level
seen during the Great Depression is
there a danger of a rerun of the
smoot-hawley tariff and retaliatory
tariffs by other countries okay ah
history point on history smoot-hawley
was passed before the depression so it's
an interesting thing it was not a
response - it was a something and oh and
a lot of people say that protectionism
you know cause were greatly deep in the
Great Depression which actually doesn't
hold up when you do the economics
carefully it's just not that's that's
another one of those trying to make a
I'm against protectionism but that's
trying to make it more of a villain than
it was I don't think there's a whole I
think that this protectionist thing is
greatly overstated United States Obama
administration's sure it has protected
this protectionist wing of the
Democratic Party there always is and but
there is actually I think a less
outright protectionist sentiment now
than there was in the 1980s and yet we
never did actually go heavily
protectionist in the 80s on the reason
is that there are international
agreements and this incoming
administration is a very
internationalist minded group believes
in the honoring treaties it's not going
to rip up the trade agreements we have
they might very well refuse to spend
political capital on new trade
agreements I don't if I was advising I
would say you know don't resurrecting
the corpse of Doha is not a is not a
priority for this administration but but
really ripping up the agreements we've
got I just don't think it's going to
happen and I don't see of this
remarkably little sign that anyone else
is getting into protectionism either I
mean I look at Latin America and look at
some of the countries that had terrible
crises look at Argentina which had there
know the
the mother of all currency crises in
2002 and they in many ways returned to a
populist economic stance but they did
not return to the inward-looking
economic policies of the Peroni era so I
just don't I think protectionism is just
not a big it's not nearly as big a risk
as people imagined in today's world
given the similarity of the current
economic crisis to Japan's lost decade
how real is the risk that the Dow Jones
and SP 500 will suffer a similar fate to
that of the Nikkei which is now at 20%
of its 89 peak yeah boy
I don't do stock price forecasts or
windows the only other thing I would say
is that as I recall it's been a long
time since I looked at these numbers but
if I recall at the eds peak the Nikkei
was had a price earnings ratio of about
60 so although we've had some pretty out
of line stock prices not like that so I
think would be hard to say that we would
you know would be hard to match that I
mean this is you know unless we really
do slide into a something even worse
economically than I think I think would
be hard to do that badly
famous last words I hope not um what do
you think the risk is of civil unrest
abroad arising from the global financial
crisis and if anywhere where what do I
know nobody knows you know when I was in
the US government I got my first ever
classified paper with something from
from a CIA memo on the on the then
global financial crisis what we thought
was that was nothing compared with now
but anyway it was and you know had all
the warnings secret no for no contract
profiting in court conduct and and what
it was was a set of completely unhelpful
speculations about possible unrest in
Mexico and other places and they have no
idea and I'm in the same position right
now i D
we gather that the Chinese are extremely
concerned that seeing their growth rate
slipped from you know 11 percent to 6
percent might cause major unrest I have
no idea whether they're right about that
if anybody knows what the hell is going
on in Greece
I just don't know what is the long-term
effects of the economic meltdown a lower
standard of living more government
control over the economy yeah lower
standard of living if we recover no not
at all I mean this is that this is
Keynes again John Mayer Keynes wrote as
the Great Depression was occurring that
we have magneto trouble he said which is
more or less alternative anyways you
know we got a problem with the
electrical system but the engine that
doesn't mean the engine that the whole
car is broken if we can fix this part
will be back and rolling again and
that's basically where we are right now
it's the fundamental productivity and so
on is is not at all effective this is a
financial fiscal screw-up and if we can
fix it we will be back on track more
government control over the economy more
government intervention in the economy
for sure the you know we're relearning
the lessons our grandfathers learned
we're relearning that financial system
is has to have a lot of regulation and
oversight because when banks go down
they can take the rest of the economy
with them and so you have to have
certainly more financial regulation and
I suppose there's probably a change in
our whole attitude right the I think the
era of Ronald Reagan's dictum government
is not the solution government is the
problem it has probably just ended we've
just seen that there are some things
from which in fact government is has to
be the solution so we'll be more
sympathetic towards government
intervention but I do not expect to see
a large scale I mean actually what's
happening now is a lot of sort of
backdoor nationalization of the
financial system
fact that we you know when that when the
tarp was was announced I couldn't resist
you know putting on my
best fake Russian accent you know
commissar Paulson has seized the
economy's commanding Heights but but but
that was clearly not the intention that
I write it and and even if I wouldn't be
surprised if we see you know substan a
pretty heavy hand of the Obama
administration on the financial system
for the first year or two but but that
will be temporary nobody you know it'll
be like Sweden which actually did
nationalize a large part of its banking
system but then sold it back and nobody
wants to do that now how is it possible
the SEC was so blind in the Madoff Ponzi
scheme and does the incoming SEC
chairwoman have the chops to do whatever
needs to be done yeah well the answer in
I don't know I don't know the the new
SEC chair so I can't I can't say any you
know the little bit I understand that
yes there were some connections there
were some personal ties but you know
never underestimate simple stupidity and
obtuseness a real a lot of things that
happened now where I think the
combination of reluctance to rock the
boat and just difficulty and getting
past the incredulity factor have been a
big issue I'm not I've had in areas that
I don't know so well I've had the same
problem I mean my next-door neighbor at
the Woodrow Wilson School is is the head
of our law and public affairs program
and she was telling me several years ago
you've got to do something you've got to
look into what's happening at the
Justice Department they're stuffing it
full of of people from Bible schools and
I said yeah yeah and of course it was
exactly true that's exactly what was
happening but I because I didn't know
that area I found that just hard to
believe and there it was so that's I so
I think it was just the you know it was
just hard to believe that this could be
true so I was probably just brushed off
as a as a possibility
is there another shoe to drop and if so
what is it or we barefoot economically
speaking yeah I like that yeah Wow you
know you keep on for thinking that
you've seen everything but I think we
still haven't seen the full hedge fund
unwind we probably are some of those
international crises have not yet come
to full fruition you know with the we
haven't seen the full bus stop in the
European periphery yet there's probably
something big I'm missing commercial
real estate a lot of that has been
discounted but probably not all of it
but God knows there's probably something
huge out there that we're not thinking
about because that's the thing when you
have this kind of crisis basically
everything that can go belly-up does and
so there will be some more things going
if there ever was a point that we would
could have prevented the situation we're
in now what would it have been oh boy
you know I think politically it was
never going to happen it could have
looked in a better world people would
have sat there sort of late fall of 1998
and and said okay LTCM LTCM
when it failed that produced a freeze up
in the world financial system very much
like what we had now more recently it
was there were several weeks when
everything was really frightening I
remember I was at a briefing at the New
York Fed in the middle of that and they
were just it was they were terrified
I remember that what someone asked you
know what can be done about this crisis
and actually
senior monetary officials said pray and
then it ended but we never quite knew
how is very you know Greenspan and Rubin
acted very confident and somehow the
whole thing went away and in a in a
better world the all of the great and
good would have said you know we between
this Asian crisis and what happened with
LTCM obviously the world has gotten very
dangerous in ways that we were not to
contractive and what we really need to
do is consider a very substantial
expansion of regulation very substantial
you know basically we need to have
something like the way we regulate and
safeguard commercial banks extended to a
wide range of financial institutions and
that would have prevented the crisis
we've had now but nothing like that was
remotely on the plate at the time you
know this was the time when now phil
gramm was still pushing for ever more
deregulation this was a time when Alan
Greenspan was was viewed as a demigod
and he thought that there was never any
need for more regulation
so if we say economically could we have
done something ten years ago to have
headed off this crisis yes
politically psychologically it was just
never going to happen we're almost out
of time but before asking the last
question we have a couple important
matters to take care of first let me
remind members of future speakers in
January we have a series of CEOs on the
8th of January we have the CEO of Nasdaq
on January 13th we have the president
and CEO of ConocoPhillips and on January
15th we'll have the CEO of AIG and
yeah second I'd like to present our
speaker with the coveted National Press
Club coffee mo for his caffeine fix
and for my last question what are you
gonna do with that 1.4 million dollars
you got from the Nobel Committee first
of all last I looked it was down to
about 1.2 because of the rising dollar
we have not a no idea Park it someplace
extremely extremely safe until we figure
it out it's no that's what one of the
best congratulatory letters I had was
congratulations now if only you can find
a bank to put it in so I don't know what
we're gonna do is the answer thank you
thanks